okay it's a bit late everything sorry
about that
I was somehow totally screwing up the
numbering I wanted to I knew that I had
to go to four five ten but I somehow
miss clicked it and then everything got
down the drain
and took a moment you said this said
sorry okay playing each s again I think
I had him just one game per diem the
game before and we have a we have an
Italian game what the heck is Bishop a6
really
okay give me the porn if we should be a
success funky okay hmm I can't even play
Bishop g4 now
[Music]
see 6 yeah cover let's cover this Missy
pond very funny I just win the T for
porn for almost nothing early on
yeah Bishop g4 now is the next immediate
IDM queen is bad not bad on f6 anyway so
it's nice Bishop g4 is also an idea here
white certainly does not want to be a
king
I mean hey let's finally AE played
Bishop a6 with the same tactic let's say
yeah Bishop a6 was not taking a power
line and we're just putting the the
bishop there to show that this is not
blundering a pawn but he gives me the
pawn what gives me the pony ok take the
money and run
yeah maybe there is create five try to
make it more difficult for me to move
him the a porn but yeah I don't know
what is before it's two points down
I mean and relatively important pawns
the center pawn and wanted one keep on
for King safety okay take a to the whole
time but do you really need a third
problem
you're probably not
well you trying to swindle me
yourself pin alert
you
you
for that but I was such a southern
sneeze I'm happy that I got the if the
microphone switched off at the liquid
movement yeah so we are in the rook
ending and I've got two extra points
very nice nope not going to give
anything back did you offer drawn there
what's the point
yeah such a majority is really good to
have
here we go
yeah it's nice it can slowly make
progress in not rushing things
okay hey don't need to do that I can
take on b2 also it
probably not played in the most precise
way it's still up for mutual you know
well what's the point people
okay now I'm not going to rematch you if
you're going to be total ass I'm sorry I
don't understand it
you want to reimagine you you act like a
child or what not not in a million years
okay so we have a the Italian him that's
really funky he's sick he's just like
into thin air
okay thank you
and then he has to turn them just just
upon yeah various ways to trying to
convert I didn't I didn't take any
additional parts I mean the big Center
porn it's nice and he gifted me another
one their age three-point with
development hello you should probably
avoid the Queen's radar just to have
some vague hope rather sweet know the
ending is just going to be totally
hopeless no counterplay whatsoever then
I'm going to it's hard to spoil this
what I'm trying to say even if you play
it a bit stupid way and I think where
are we here
careful's I think here white to
something else not entirely sure what's
best forgotten the line yeah oftentimes
they they play Queen b3 here and like
being ready to make a draw after which
you never make the draw but rather go
back and this is a bit different to the
game of
where I'm allowing or we're basically
conceding the night activity going to
yourself just not sure what to draw so
here I'm already a little bit more
comfortable than I usually am and then
after this it's already looking a little
bit odd this should be three or ever is
of course better here because you have
this x-ray against c7 now I can take but
this is of course not leading to
anything you know okay guys thanks for
watching